[Música]
bienvenidos a esta entrevista exclusiva
de france 24 y de radio france
internacional
estamos en nuakchot mauritania y nuestro
invitado es el presidente mauritano
mohamed uld ghazuani para esta
entrevista me acompaña christophe y éste
rf bienvenido un señor presidente muchas
gracias señor presidente quiero empezar
por la situación en túnez hace unos días
el presidente de caixa y el decidió
deponer a su primer ministro y suspender
el parlamento la pregunta es muy
sencilla para usted se trata en este
caso de un golpe de estado
de vocación
estamos siguiendo con mucha atención la
situación en túnez yo mismo tuve una
llamada telefónica con el presidente
camps ayer para informarnos sobre la
situación actual
y para tener una idea que viniera
directamente de los tunecinos y sobre
todo del presidente de la republica
que no surgía del cine sean directamente
ser tour y previsional de la república
la explicación que sea tan
precisa
las explicaciones que escuche por parte
del presidente describen una situación
de bloqueo
la cual él dijo que está en situación de
enfrentar desde hace un tiempo y que se
encontró en este panorama que trató de
desbloquear la en la medida de lo
posible
[Música]
que él
si la aceptación
de la de broker y que la situación que
vive túnez es una situación de pandemia
si ustedes saben bien el nivel de
propagación de la pandemia madurez como
sería la banda de propagación de la
pandemia a kenyi
así es la situación
sí
el presidente quiso explicarme que
estaba en una situación de bloqueo que
era necesario enfrentar
en los medios constitucionales estaban
ahí que se trataba del artículo 80 de la
constitución tunecina
durante esa conversación usted demostró
su apoyo le dijo entiendo lo que está
haciendo porque hay una situación de
bloqueo o le dijo como muchas otras
cancillerías occidentales es necesario
volver lo más pronto posible al orden
constitucional
escuché de la propia boca del presidente
que él mismo era un profesor de derecho
constitucional y que no corrían riesgo
de cometer errores es decir actuar por
fuera de la constitución
y el artículo 80 de la constitución
tunecina
le confiere el derecho o el poder más
exactamente
de suspender el parlamento tunecino
durante un mes y por esa razón hay
acciones o medidas que se deben llamar
como informar tanto al presidente de la
asamblea nacional como al primer
ministro el dice haber hecho todo eso
en pocas palabras confía en él es más a
los tunecinos a los que se les debe
preguntar si confían en su presidente
pero imagina faso
malí en burkina faso hay muchas voces
que se están alzando incluso en los
altos mandos del estado para decir que
hay que dialogar con los líderes
yihadistas como amado okupa que piensa
al respecto
se llame a tanque
nunca escuché nunca me enteré que a
nivel de los estados esté preconizando
este enfoque
el primer ministro de transición
maliense lo dijo se han escuchado
personas en burkina faso que dicen que
no es posible luchar eternamente lo que
hay que dialogar no sabes de un respecto
por la zeta
nosotros respetamos la voluntad y la
soberanía de los estados de parte de uno
en apoyo
en cuanto al hecho de compartir o no un
enfoque me parece que cada uno es muy
soberano de poder y su posición personal
no
nosotros no hemos dialogado con
terroristas no hemos anunciado que
tenemos la intención de hacerlo
por fortuna mauritania se ha librado
relativamente del terrorismo en los
últimos diez años será precisamente tal
vez porque hubo una pacto de no agresión
con ciertos grupos yihadistas
ya estás usando esa lección del señor
ya pasó
a menudo oigo afirmaciones de este tipo
pienso que no conozco a nadie oa ningún
país que no desee estar en seguridad
aunque sea plano
al respecto decimos gracias a dios que
estamos seguros
pero pienso que la pregunta que se
debería hacer es
aquel frío a qué precio están en esa
situación
era el espejo
el precio está ahí no estamos pagando a
cumplir qué
desde el principio entendimos esta
problemática de seguridad es
indispensable
pero ya
no se puede hacer nada sin estar seguro
no hay desarrollo bajo la inseguridad y
que era necesario hacer de la seguridad
una prioridad de la sécurité y la
priority se ofrece
es verdad eso nos ha costado caro al
privilegiar la seguridad de expensas de
ciertos departamentos o sectores
sociales
principalmente en la salud la educación
y
los aspectos sociales y estamos
comprometidos hasta el punto de estar en
capacidad de defendernos
[Música]
hoy en día en el momento en el que les
hablo estamos sobre 2.300 kilómetros de
frontera con mali
estamos sobre unos 400 con argelia
y todo esto ocurre en un desierto en el
cual los grupos terroristas pueden
actuar como quieren
pero nosotros construimos bases a lo
largo de todas estas fronteras
tenemos unidades que circulan y vigilan
día y noche
tenemos aviones equipados con medios de
observación
que hacen reconocimientos y que trabajan
mucho sobre esto tenemos otros medios
para vigilar todas las actividades que
pueden generar seguridad en nuestro país
es tres activistas
a trenes securities
es un esfuerzo
y nos felicitamos por el hecho de que
nuestro esfuerzo nos ha permitido
ponernos en la situación en la que
estamos
una de las vías humanos
y
usted hablaba del norte de mali francia
anunció que la operación marcan cerré
configuraría pero que también se
reduciría en términos de cantidad de
tropas habrá la mitad de efectivos para
finales de 2022 se cerraron varias bases
militares francesas en el norte de mali
entre esa es la de tombuctú que no está
tan lejos
que teme que esa zona que usted mismo
definió como una zona de peligro sea de
nuevo retomada por los yihadistas y que
de nuevo los financia usted es directa
pero segura
para pasar ya sé que voy a decirles lo
que pienso al respecto
sé que efectivamente puede disminuir el
control de la situación que ya es
suficientemente frágil
se llama fácil pero confío en la
voluntad de francia que ha acompañado al
g5 desde el 2012 o 2011
el uso de miles de
operaciones al que hay que dar placer
para abarcar
desde su operación serbal que fue
reemplazada por marcan
efectivamente el acompañamiento y la
asociación con francia en este aspecto
de seguridad del g5 ha traído muchas
cosas y los resultados que ya se han
obtenido son positivos
yo pienso que francia que tiene un papel
en esos resultados obtenidos no corre el
riesgo de comprometer la seguridad
y para que esta lucha anti yihadista sea
más eficaz pues sería necesario que el
g5 sanj el monte también operaciones
conjuntas con el ejército argelino no
sería necesario que las investigaciones
del g5 compartan informaciones con las
investigaciones argelinas
estas cosas de
importancia del árbol
estoy totalmente de acuerdo con usted
sobre la importancia de un papel jugado
por argelia o sobre el hecho de que
argelia es de ahí argelia comparte
fronteras con tres países del g5
próxima
carmen en portada y esta proximidad de
todas maneras es importante debe ser
tomada en consideración en el marco de
la lucha contra el terrorismo en nuestra
región
la pasé a la
montaña
hacemos a la situación de mauritania su
predecesor el presidente mohamed uld
abdel aziz fue inculpado en marzo por
conducción lavado de dinero
enriquecimiento ilícito
está tras los barrotes desde hace un
poco más de un mes lo acusa a usted
directamente de ser el instigador de
estos altercados con la justicia por
razones puramente políticas
axel más tarde
actualmente estando en manos de la
justicia no tendría mucho que añadir a
esto
porque eso es lo que se debe hacer no
involucrarme en los asuntos de la
justicia
usted habla de la investigación
parlamentaria la cual inició en enero de
unas semanas después de que su
predecesor tratará de retomar el control
del partido en el poder de unión por la
república
la coincidencia de fechas no es algo
inquietante
[Aplausos]
no yo no puedo hacer
no no veo cómo podría ser inquietante
npr es un partido
útil efectivamente era la herramienta
política del poder establecido
si hablas
el pr se compone como cualquier partido
por una cierta cantidad de hombres y
mujeres
[Música]
el general ashfaq conquista por frío
parte
no pienso que sea posible apropiarse de
los partidos ni considerar que sea un
objeto
se trata de un partido compuesto por
directivas por militantes
la we left
son personas que toman posición donde
quieren dar pasos para que toque
no creo que sea posible ligar estos dos
eventos
pero usted no aprecio el hecho de que su
predecesor haya querido retomar el
control de ese partido no sé cls de
actuar de papel no son las directivas
del partido y son los diputados del
partido quienes no lo apreciaron
nosotros sabemos que contribuye al
contrario contribuye mucho a calmar a
esa población tanto a nivel del partido
como del parlamento
pero su predecesor afirma que los
diputados que lanzaron esa investigación
parlamentaria fueron sobornados por
miembros provenientes de su círculo con
el objetivo de que esa investigación se
abriera que le diría
no sé
primero yo nunca lo supe así
reto a cualquiera decir que fue
sobornado para tomar una decisión
yo cuál era la situación porque conozco
bien la situación que ese que provee
muchos esfuerzos justamente para calmar
esa situación existe acción
así que no había necesidad de sobornar a
nadie chicos y debían ser sobornados era
para nada más se por carmen
señor presidente cuando uno lee ese
informe de la investigación
parlamentaria se tiene la impresión de
que hay una verdadera empresa de
depredación de nepotismo sobre el dinero
público eso le sorprendió y le aseguro
que yo nunca leyes nunca leyó ese
informe le aseguro que yo nunca había
escuchado hablar de él
he oído hablar de eso le sorprendieron
algunas cosas
[Música]
se para de villiers a que se pase en
realidad no vale la pena decirle lo que
pensé de todo esto porque consideré que
era un archivo que estaba en dos niveles
que no me involucraba
primero el parlamento luego la justicia
me comen pero de todas maneras usted era
su amigo desde hacía 40 años su socio
más cercano muchas personas piensan
cuando leen todo esto que no es posible
que lo ignorará que debía estar enterado
de lo que estaba pasando
tenía otras cosas que hacer
nunca sospechó nada de lo que estaba
ocurriendo no no no no
nunca lo sospeche
nunca lo sospeche efectiva por retener
para volver un poco sobre el tema puedo
decirle que a la persona no como
presidente me sorprendió lo que se
refirió en ese documento
no sintió que su parte tal vez una
manera de considerarlo como su eterno
segundo una especie de desprecio frente
a sus allegados
no se le llama el colegio es que antes
de que se pase por un par de fashion
no nunca me sorprendieron muchas cosas
en lo que pasó hablándoles francamente
no pensé es una situación no pensé que
sería posible estar en la situación en
la que estuvimos
en ese barrio pero una vez ocurrida
pienso que también hay que vivirla
pero correctamente pero le deja un sabor
amargo está decepcionado no
sus ojos hablan perdón sus ojos hablan
por usted
déjenlos hablar entonces
en junio de 2019 hizo campaña por usted
dice que usted lo traicionó es una
afirmación fuerte por supuesto para
alguien convierte con
dije que yo no lo traicioné yo no lo
traicioné él lo traicionó
pues servirá que se pregúntenle a él
y si el antiguo presidente restituye una
parte de los bienes mal adquiridos que
eventualmente habría obtenido podría
evitar un proceso
no me corresponde tomar decisiones o
tomar posiciones al respecto
pero se consideró que desde que se le
entregó el informe a la justicia es
mejor esperar que la justicia tome una
decisión
el presidente así renunció un tercer
mandato y hoy en día está en la cárcel
no será ese el mejor argumento para los
presidentes del continente o de otras
partes que quieren quedarse en el poder
en otras palabras podrían pensar si me
voy corro el riesgo de terminar tras las
rejas
por ejemplo la canción de ella
si he escuchado un poco de esa
interpretación
creo que los que se quieren aferrar al
poder y no aceptar la alternancia no
necesitan situaciones como esta para
justificar los espías o cosa por este
fin
se le considera
qué
y los que quieren y consideran que la
alternancia es necesaria
no se hundirán por el hecho de que
alguien pueda comparecer ante la
justicia
o ser interrogado sobre ciertas cosas
gracias señor presidente por habernos
concedido esta entrevista y gracias a
ustedes por habernos seguido a nuestras
dos cadenas
324 y radio falsamente nacional
[Música]